MS-13-- President Trump talks about them a lot. He's mentioned them 198 times since he became president according to one database of everything that he said publicly. Here he is in Nashville in May.
MS-13——特朗普总统经常谈论他们。据一个记录他所有公开言论的数据库统计，自他担任总统以来，他已经提到了他们198次。这是他五月份在纳什维尔时的讲话。
This vicious gang has transformed the once peaceful, beautiful communities that I know so well. I know them all. Into blood stained killing fields. Savagely murdering, raping, and mutilating, their victims.
这个恶毒的帮派已经把我所熟知的那些曾经宁静、美丽的社区变成了血迹斑斑的杀戮场。我非常了解他们。他们残忍地谋杀、强奸并肢解了他们的受害者。
The communities he knows well are on Long Island, near where he grew up in Queens. MS-13 is a particularly brutal gang. Originally formed in Los Angeles in the 1980s by immigrants and refugees from Central America. Their weapons of choice tend to be machetes and baseball bats. MS-13 has been especially violent lately on Long Island. Last year the president spoke there at Suffolk County Community College. The audience was filled with law enforcement of various kinds-- immigration and customs officials, FBI agents, members of the local police, in their dress uniforms and white gloves.
他所熟知的社区位于长岛，靠近他长大的皇后区。MS-13是一个极其残暴的帮派，最初由来自中美洲的移民和难民于20世纪80年代在洛杉矶成立。他们惯用的武器通常是砍刀和棒球棍。最近，MS-13在长岛尤为猖獗。去年，总统在萨福克县社区学院发表了讲话。听众席坐满了各种执法人员——移民和海关官员、联邦调查局特工、当地警察，他们都穿着制服、戴着白手套。
And the president praised law enforcement for doing a great job eradicating MS-13-- arresting gang members, throwing them in jail, deporting them.
总统称赞执法部门在铲除MS-13方面做得非常好——逮捕帮派成员、将他们投进监狱、驱逐出境。
And I want to just tell you all together, right now. And the reason I came, this is the most important sentence to me. On behalf of the American people, I want to say, thank you. Thank you very much. Thank you.
我现在想对你们所有人说，我之所以来到这里，是因为这一句对我来说最重要的话：我谨代表美国人民，向你们表示感谢。非常感谢你们。谢谢。
At this speech, he shook hands with officers from the Suffolk County Police Department. Our story today is about that police department, and it documents the opposite. It documents them failing repeatedly in fighting MS-13. Particularly when the victims were Latino immigrant kids.
在那次演讲中，他与萨福克县警察局的警官们握了手。我们今天的故事就是关于那个警察局的，但它记录的却是事实的另一面。它记录了他们在一再打击MS-13过程中的失职。特别是在受害者是拉丁裔移民孩子时。
In the end, there were 18 murders in 16 months. Literally, teenagers were disappearing. And for a long time, the Suffolk County Police did very little to investigate. Made the same mistakes over and over. Missed clues, missed leads. Brushed aside distraught parents who were looking for their kids. Parents who had information that might have been helpful.
最终，在16个月内发生了18起谋杀案。青少年们接二连三地失踪了。很长一段时间里，萨福克县警方在调查方面几乎毫无作为。他们一而再、再而三地犯同样的错误，错过线索，错过方向，把那些寻找失踪孩子、心急如焚的父母打发走，而这些父母原本掌握着可能有用的信息。
Investigative reporter Hannah Dreier from ProPublica, who spent the last year in Suffolk County reporting on MS-13 and the police there. And she's found pervasive problems in how the Suffolk County Police Department treats Latinos in general. Problems which dramatically slowed their response to this MS-13 murder spree. And let's just get right to it. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Here's Hannah Dreier.
ProPublica的调查记者汉娜·德雷尔（Hannah Dreier）去年一年都在萨福克县报道MS-13和当地警方的情况。她发现萨福克县警察局在对待拉丁裔群体方面普遍存在问题，这些问题极大地减缓了他们对MS-13杀戮狂潮的反应。让我们切入正题。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，下面是汉娜·德雷尔。
The first teenager who was murdered was Miguel Garcia Moran. His family always teased his mom, Carlota, over how over protective she was. When Miguel was a toddler, back in Ecuador, she put chicken wire around their house to keep him from running down the street. When the family got green cards and moved to Suffolk County, she imposed a strict 10 PM curfew.
第一个被谋杀的少年是米格尔·加西亚·莫兰。他的家人总是取笑他的母亲卡洛塔太爱操心。米格尔还是个蹒跚学步的孩子时，在厄瓜多尔，她就在房子周围围上铁丝网，防止他跑向街道。当家人拿到绿卡搬到萨福克县后，她强加了严格的晚上10点门禁。
And when he wanted to play video games at a neighbor's house on a cold Friday afternoon, in February of 2016, Carlota drove him there, a few blocks away, even though he had just turned 15 and could have walked over. Carlota got home later that evening around 7:30 with some dinner for Miguel. She called out his name. When he didn't answer, she felt a jolt of alarm. She texted him to ask where he was. No response.
2016年2月一个寒冷的周五下午，当他想去邻居家玩电子游戏时，尽管米格尔刚满15岁，本可以走过去，但卡洛塔还是开车送他去了几条街外的地方。那天晚上7点半左右，卡洛塔带着晚餐回到家，喊他的名字。当没人回应时，她感到一阵恐慌。她发短信问他在哪，没有回复。
She texted him a third, a fourth, a fifth time. By midnight, Carlota's stomach was clenched with dread. Miguel never failed to let her know where he was. He never missed his curfew. He was even too afraid to go to sleepovers. By 2:00 AM, she couldn't wait any longer. She and her boyfriend, Abraham Chaparro, got in the car and started driving.
她发了第三次、第四次、第五次短信。到了午夜，卡洛塔因为恐惧而胃部绞痛。米格尔从不隐瞒自己的行踪，也从不违反门禁。他甚至连去朋友家过夜都不敢。凌晨2点，她再也等不下去了，她和男友亚伯拉罕·查帕罗坐上车，开始四处寻找。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And I was like, where's Miguel. What happened to Miguel?
我说，米格尔在哪？米格尔发生了什么事？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He normally, he calls me, every 5, every 10 minutes.
他通常每5或10分钟就会给我打个电话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But during all those hours, they seemed just so long, and I didn't know whether I should scream, or cry. I just felt like I was losing the whole world at that moment.
但在那几个小时里，每一分钟都显得如此漫长，我不知道我是该尖叫还是该哭。那一刻，我感觉自己仿佛失去了整个世界。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
At that point, I was just saying, you know, it's like someone stole my son.
在那一刻，我一直在说，就像有人偷走了我的儿子。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
After hours of searching the streets, Carlota finally went home. She sat down on her bed, fully clothed, and waited for the sun to come up, so she and Abraham could go to the police station. When they got there, two Suffolk County Police officers were sitting on an elevated platform, behind the counter, drinking coffee.
在街上搜寻了几个小时后，卡洛塔终于回了家。她和衣坐在床上，等待天亮，这样她和亚伯拉罕就能去警察局。他们到达时，两名萨福克县警察正坐在柜台后的高台上喝咖啡。
Carlota only speaks Spanish. But her boyfriend, Abraham, has lived in the US for years, and speaks some English. Abraham helped her give the officers the basics. The missing kid was Miguel Garcia Moran, 15 years old, tall, and big, 235 pounds, lived in the town of Brentwood, last seen at a friend's house the night before. A detective named Luis Perez was assigned to the case. He's a veteran detective in Brentwood, and one of the few officers on the force who speaks Spanish. The police told Carlota and Abraham that some officers were going to drive around their neighborhood to look for Miguel. But really, they shouldn't be too concerned.
卡洛塔只会说西班牙语，但她的男友亚伯拉罕在美国住过几年，会说一点英语。亚伯拉罕帮她向警官提供了基本情况：失踪者是15岁的米格尔·加西亚·莫兰，个子很高，体重235磅，住在布伦特伍德镇，最后一次露面是在前一天晚上朋友家里。一位名叫路易斯·佩雷斯的探员被分派到此案。他是布伦特伍德的一名资深探员，也是警局里为数不多会说西班牙语的警官之一。警方告诉卡洛塔和亚伯拉罕，会有警员开车在社区周围寻找米格尔，但他们其实不必太过担心。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And they said, look, it's Saturday. Your son's going to be back on Monday. He's probably just hanging out with friends. But I said, no, my son would never do that. He always comes home early. This isn't like him.
他们说，看，现在是周六。你儿子周一就会回来。他可能只是和朋友出去了。但我说，不，我儿子绝不会那样做。他总是很早就回家，这不像他的作风。
At this point, Miguel had been missing for 24 hours, which in a missing persons case are the most crucial. There's a truism in law enforcement-- the first 24 hours are the only 24 hours. The New York City Police Department has a checklist of dozens of things officers have to do immediately if a minor goes missing. Things like, talking to the kids' friends, checking their social media accounts, and putting out a press release.
此时，米格尔已经失踪了24小时，这在失踪人口案件中是最关键的时间。执法部门有一句格言——前24小时是唯一的24小时。纽约市警察局有一份清单，列出了如果未成年人失踪，警官必须立即做的几十件事，比如与孩子的同学们交谈、检查他们的社交媒体账号，以及发布新闻稿。
Nassau County, which borders Suffolk County on Long Island, has an even more extensive protocol, which includes alerting state officials within two hours of taking a report. The Suffolk County Police handbook, on the other hand, has no checklist for what to do if a minor goes missing. Nothing about talking to the kid's friends. Nothing about social media. Nothing about a press release. In the whole handbook, there are basically two paragraphs about what to do if a minor is reported missing. And they boil down to take a report, search the area where they live. That's it.
长岛上与萨福克县接壤的拿骚县，其规程更为详尽，其中包括在接到报案后两小时内向州政府官员发出预警。而萨福克县警方的手册里，根本没有关于未成年人失踪该如何操作的清单。没有关于与孩子同学交谈的内容，没有社交媒体相关信息，也没有发布新闻稿的说明。整本手册里，关于报案后该做什么只有两段话，总结起来就是：做笔录，搜查居住区域。就这样。
So on Sunday, two days after Miguel went missing, that's what the Suffolk County Police did. They searched the woods closest to Carlota's home. And they also talked to the neighbors. On Monday, three days after Miguel went missing, the police put out a press release and a photo of Miguel in a green shirt with a red bandanna around his head. It said, quote, "Detectives do not believe there is foul play involved in Moran's disappearance." And they listed Miguel as a runaway, which Carlota found extra upsetting.
所以周日，在米格尔失踪两天后，萨福克县警方就是这么做的。他们搜查了离卡洛塔家最近的树林，也询问了邻居。周一，即米格尔失踪三天后，警方发布了一份新闻稿，附上了米格尔身穿绿衬衫、头上系着红头巾的照片。稿件称，引用：“侦探们认为莫兰的失踪不涉及刑事犯罪。”他们将米格尔列为离家出走者，这让卡洛塔感到格外痛苦。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I felt a lot of indignation because they would say that, oh, he just ran away from home. And I'd think, why would you say that?
我感到非常愤怒，因为他们那样说，噢，他只是离家出走了。我会想，你们凭什么这么说？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Why would you say that he ran away from home when I have proof? I have pictures of us, like, going to the store. Us going to different places, even from that day, where we went to the firefighters.
我明明有证据，为什么你们要说他是离家出走的？我有我们一起去商店、去不同地方的照片，甚至那天我们还一起去了消防站。
The day Miguel disappeared, he and Carlota had gone to the firehouse to fill out an application. He wanted to join the volunteer firefighters. They spent the morning and afternoon together as they often did on weekends. Miguel liked to walk with his arms slung around his mother's shoulders. At 5' 10", he towered over her.
米格尔失踪那天，他和卡洛塔去消防站填了一份申请表，他想加入志愿消防员。他们像往常的周末一样一起度过了上午和下午。米格尔喜欢手臂搭在母亲的肩膀上走路。他身高5英尺10英寸，比她高出一大截。
Miguel was a total mama's boy. For his 15th birthday, a few months earlier, his older sister helped him get Carlota's name tattooed on his arm. So to Carlota, the thought that Miguel had run away from home was insane. She tried to explain this to the police, but they still listed him as a runaway. And when they did that, the police were acting against guidelines from multiple agencies.
米格尔是个典型的“妈宝”。几个月前他15岁生日时，姐姐帮他在手臂上纹上了卡洛塔的名字。所以对卡洛塔来说，米格尔离家出走的想法是荒谬的。她试图向警方解释这一点，但他们仍然把他列为离家出走。这样做时，警方实际上违背了多个机构的指导方针。
According to the National Center for Missing and Exploited Children, and the Department of Justice, law enforcement should quote, "Assume the child is at risk, until investigative facts contradict that assumption." When a kid is listed as a runaway instead of as a missing or endangered person, it basically stops an investigation before it starts. Listing Miguel as a runaway is the first big mistake the police make. They'll be many more.
根据国家失踪与受剥削儿童中心和司法部的说法，执法部门应当“假设孩子处于危险之中，直到调查事实反驳这一假设”。当一个孩子被列为离家出走而不是失踪或处于危险状态的人时，这基本上在调查开始之前就将其扼杀了。将米格尔列为离家出走是警方犯下的第一个重大错误。而他们之后还会犯更多错误。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
My hope, truthfully, was that if I go to the police they would help us. You know, this was just a disaster. A disaster.
说实话，我当初的希望是，如果我们去报警，他们能帮助我们。你知道，这简直是一场灾难。一场灾难。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Going to the police was a disaster.
报警成了一场灾难。
After days with no apparent progress from police, Carlota, realized she needed a new strategy. She started going around posting missing person flyers, which she wrote herself because the police had not made any. She searched for Miguel every day on residential streets, strip malls, at American Eagle, his favorite clothing store, and in the woods. Including one patch of forest that the police call the killing fields. It's a gang hang out and dumping ground for bodies.
在警方明显没有取得进展几天后，卡洛塔意识到她需要一个新的策略。她开始到处张贴失踪人员传单，因为警方从未制作过。她每天在住宅区、露天购物中心、米格尔最喜欢的服装店美国鹰（American Eagle）和树林里寻找米格尔。其中包括一片警察称为“杀戮场”的林区。那里是帮派聚集地和尸体处理场所。
The trees are so dense there that it's hard to see very far into them. Condoms and cigar wrappers and empty spray paint cans blanket the ground. At the heart of these woods is an abandoned psychiatric hospital. The dozens of possibilities she'd been replaying in her head, we're converging on a single fear, MS-13. She knew they were active in Brentwood, but she didn't know much more.
那里的树木茂密，很难看清远处。避孕套、雪茄包装纸和空喷漆罐铺满了地面。这片树林中央是一所废弃的精神病院。她在脑海中反复回想的几十种可能性，正汇聚成一个单一的恐惧：MS-13。她知道他们在布伦特伍德很活跃，但了解的并不多。
MS-13 leaders in the US are often really young, like high school aged. On Long Island, some of the most brutal MS-13 violence has been masterminded by 15 and 16-year-olds. Brentwood high school was shared by a few MS-13 cliques. That's what they call their subgroups-- the Hollywood Locos, the Brentwood Locos, and the Sailors. They wear blue plastic rosaries and Nike Cortez sneakers. The other gangs at the school were as color coded as teams at camp.
美国境内的MS-13头目通常非常年轻，像高中生一样。在长岛，一些最残暴的MS-13暴力事件是由15、16岁的青少年策划的。布伦特伍德高中里有几个MS-13分支——这就是他们对自己小组的称呼，分别是Hollywood Locos、Brentwood Locos和Sailors。他们戴着蓝色塑料念珠，穿着耐克Cortez运动鞋。学校里的其他帮派也像夏令营里的队伍一样，通过衣服颜色进行区分。
At the time Miguel went missing, Suffolk County Police mostly left the gangs alone. Members had the run of the woods around town and the halls of the high school. Miguel's older sister, Lady, was a sophomore at Brentwood high school when Miguel went missing. Lady has a habit of narrowing her eyes when she talks. She's streetwise, but also churchgoing. She had been a natural loner all her life, unlike Miguel, who has always been teased for his stutter, and was desperate to seem cool.
米格尔失踪时，萨福克县警方基本上放任这些帮派不管。成员们在镇上的树林和高中走廊里横行霸道。米格尔的姐姐莱迪在米格尔失踪时是布伦特伍德高中的二年级学生。莱迪说话时习惯眯起眼睛。她很懂世故，但也经常去教堂。她一生中大部分时间都是一个天生的独行侠，不像米格尔，他总是因为口吃被取笑，拼命想显得酷一点。
At Brentwood high school, Lady, had become even more standoffish to keep the gang kids away, which wasn't always easy because gang members aggressively approach new students at school and pressure them to join.
在布伦特伍德高中，为了让帮派孩子远离自己，莱迪变得更加疏离，但这并不容易，因为帮派成员会在学校积极接触新生，并强迫他们加入。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
If they didn't see you with a stern look in your face, or if they didn't see you mad, then they would treat you badly.
如果他们没在你脸上看到严肃的表情，或者没看到你生气，他们就会粗暴地对待你。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It was different for me because I had a strong temper. But Miguel was not like that. He was weak. He was the spoiled child.
对我来说情况不同，因为我的脾气很硬。但米格尔不是那样的，他很软弱，他是被宠坏的孩子。
When Miguel started in the high school, did you tell him the things that you had learned?
当米格尔开始上高中时，你告诉过他你学到的那些事情吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I would tell him, you know, when you're changing period from one class to the other, don't talk to certain people. And he'd say, OK.
我会告诉他，你知道，当你从一门课换到另一门课时，不要和某些人说话。他说，好的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And at first, he did. He did listen to me. But then, you know, he had friends that I did not know. And I told him, do not make friends.
起初他确实听了我的。但后来，你知道，他有了我不认识的朋友。我告诉他，不要交朋友。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
A week after Miguel went missing, Carlota did an interview with a Spanish language news channel to talk about his disappearance.
米格尔失踪一周后，卡洛塔接受了一家西班牙语新闻频道的采访，谈论他的失踪。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The footage shows Carlota leaning heavily on Abraham, as the two walk through a strip mall in jackets and winter hats, taping up their missing person flyers. She says, there are so many things you hear about in this country. That the gangs go and take kids. That's what I fear the most. That they've taken him. Carlota brought up the possibility that gangs might be involved in Miguel's disappearance. But the Suffolk County Police still said no foul play was suspected and continued to list him as a runaway.
录像显示，卡洛塔沉重地依靠着亚伯拉罕，两人穿着夹克和冬帽走在露天购物中心贴失踪人员传单。她说：“在这个国家你听说过很多事情，比如帮派会去抢孩子。这是我最害怕的，他们把他带走了。”卡洛塔提到了帮派可能参与米格尔失踪的可能性。但萨福克县警方仍然称没有可疑迹象，并继续将他列为离家出走。
Another big problem with the police's treatment of these immigrant families, was they were dismissive, and sometimes even treated them like suspects. Carlota came to feel intimidated by Detective Perez. She says he seemed angry at her. He was big, like a bodybuilder, with tattoos circling his arms. One day he sat her down and accused her of knowing more than she was saying about Miguel.
警方对待这些移民家庭的另一个大问题是他们的冷漠，有时甚至把他们当作嫌疑人。卡洛塔开始感到被佩雷斯探员恐吓。她说他似乎对她很生气。他身材魁梧，像个健美运动员，双臂纹着纹身。一天，他让她坐下，指责她对米格尔的事情隐瞒了实情。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Then he started telling me, you know where he is. And I said, what? Like, why do I know where he is? I come here all the time asking where he is.
然后他开始对我说，你知道他在哪。我说，什么？为什么我知道他在哪？我一直来这问他在哪。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
If I knew where he was then I wouldn't be here. And I just wanted to hit him when he told me that. And he said, well, if you don't know where he is--
如果我知道他在哪，我就不会在这了。当他说那话时，我真想打他。他说，好吧，如果你不知道他在哪——
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
--then you should go to a witch doctor, because then, they can help you find Miguel.
——那你应该去找个巫医，因为那样他们能帮你找到米格尔。
Detective Perez told Carlota to find a brujo, which is Spanish for witch doctor, or fortune teller.
佩雷斯探员告诉卡洛塔去找个巫医（brujo）。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I don't know why he said that. It's like, I can't do anything more for you. You need to go and see the witch doctor because he just didn't want to help anymore.
我不知道他为什么要那样说。感觉就是，我不能再为你做什么了。你需要去找巫医，因为他只是不想再帮忙了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
One of the starkest ways that the police demonstrated their indifference to the families, was that they wouldn't even speak to them in their own language. This underlies so much of what went wrong. Even Detective Perez, who could speak Spanish. Lady told me something else that happened in that brujo conversation.
警方表现出对这些家庭冷漠的最显著方式之一，就是他们甚至不愿用对方的语言与他们交谈。这构成了许多错误的基础。即使是会说西班牙语的佩雷斯探员也是如此。莱迪告诉我关于那次巫医对话中发生的另一件事。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He just said, I'm not speaking Spanish anymore because this is America. Nobody speaks Spanish, only English, so why don't you just go back.
他说，我不再说西班牙语了，因为这里是美国。没人说西班牙语，只说英语，所以你们为什么不滚回去。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Even knowing that my mom doesn't speak a word of English.
即使他知道我妈妈一句英语也不会说。
How did you feel when he said that?
当他说那话时，你有什么感觉？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I felt bad. You know, because she was Latino, and to come and say this to us knowing that we needed him. That we needed for him to find someone for us.
我感觉很糟糕。因为她是拉丁裔，在明知我们需要他、需要他为我们找到人的时候，他却来对我们说这种话。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And he just simply didn't feel like speaking our language to us.
而他只是单纯地不想对我们说我们的语言。
Carlota and Lady are not unusual in Suffolk County. Though the county includes really ritzy places like the Hamptons, it also has towns like Brentwood, where families get by on minimum wage jobs, and most people speak Spanish as their first language. 20% of the county is Hispanic. But in 2016, in the entire Suffolk County Police Department, 3,500 employees, only three people were certified to interpret for Spanish speakers.
卡洛塔和莱迪在萨福克县并不罕见。尽管该县包括像汉普顿这样非常奢华的地方，但它也有布伦特伍德这样的城镇，家庭依靠最低工资工作生活，大多数人以西班牙语为第一语言。该县20%的人口是西班牙裔。但在2016年，在拥有3500名员工的整个萨福克县警察局，只有3人获得了西班牙语口译认证。
Unlike a majority of big police departments, Suffolk County doesn't give officers extra pay for knowing a second language. They do pay police well, though. They're actually one of the best paid departments in the country. Detective Perez made just under $200,000 a year, and lived in a gated community several towns away from where he works. Detective Perez wouldn't talk to me for this story, by the way. When I knocked on his door, he said he had no comment, and told me to get off his property.
与大多数大型警察部门不同，萨福克县不会因为警官会第二语言而给予额外报酬。不过，他们确实给警察支付高额薪水。他们实际上是全国待遇最好的部门之一。佩雷斯探员一年收入略低于20万美元，住在离他工作地点几个镇远的一个门禁社区。顺便说一句，佩雷斯探员不愿接受我的采访。当我敲他的门时，他说没什么可评论的，并叫我离开他的私人领地。
Almost two months after Miguel went missing, there was a breakthrough in the case. But the person who made it was not a Suffolk County Detective. It was Miguel's sister, Lady. One morning, she borrowed Abraham's cell phone and discovered that Miguel had left his Facebook account open there. She suddenly had access to his Facebook Messenger chats. She could look through all the conversations he had with his friends, up to the day he went missing.
米格尔失踪近两个月后，案件取得了突破。但做出突破的人不是萨福克县的侦探，而是米格尔的姐姐莱迪。一天早上，她借用了亚伯拉罕的手机，发现米格尔在那里登录着Facebook账号。她突然可以访问他的Facebook Messenger聊天记录。她可以查看他与朋友之间的所有对话，一直到他失踪的那天。
Here, look.
你看，在这里。
Lady showed me the messages.
莱迪向我展示了这些信息。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Yes. That was Miguel's entire messenger conversation.
是的，那就是米格尔完整的Messenger对话。
Most of them were failed attempts to flirt with girls at school. In others, he's talking about smoking weed. In one conversation, he tells a friend he wants a pair of Nike Cortez sneakers. But the friend tells him he can't wear those because they're a sign of MS-13. That's an important piece of advice. MS-13 doesn't have businesses like a normal criminal organization. And instead, commits violence for the sake of violence, killing victims with bats and machetes for minor shows of disrespect, like wearing Nike Cortez shoes without their permission.
其中大部分是与学校女生调情失败的尝试。在其他对话中，他在谈论吸大麻。在一场对话中，他告诉一个朋友他想要一双耐克Cortez运动鞋。但朋友告诉他不能穿那个，因为那是MS-13的标志。这是一个重要的建议。MS-13不像正常的犯罪组织那样有商业往来，而是为了暴力而实施暴力，仅仅因为轻微的挑衅，比如未经允许穿了耐克Cortez鞋，就用棒球棍和砍刀杀害受害者。
And then, there's just one conversation from the day Miguel disappeared. Text and audio messages between Miguel and someone named Alexander Lokote. Lokote isn't a last name. It means something like homeboy or gangster. So you can see the day that Miguel went missing. There's like 20 messages back and forth between him and Alexander.
然后，还有关于米格尔失踪当天的唯一一段对话。米格尔和一个叫“亚历山大·洛科特（Alexander Lokote）”的人之间的文字和语音信息。洛科特不是姓氏，它的意思大约是“老乡”或“黑帮成员”。所以你可以看到米格尔失踪的那一天，他和亚历山大之间有大约20条往来信息。
The conversation begins at 8:54 in the morning. And ends at 7:06 that night. Right around when Carlota was getting home and discovering that Miguel wasn't there. Alexander tells Miguel he's gotten his hands on some weed, and invites him to smoke later on with two other boys. One of the other boys is a kid named Jairo. Miguel had just started smoking weed. His mother and sister didn't even know he had tried it. Miguel seems pleased and surprised, and responds with a voice message.
对话开始于上午8:54，结束于那天晚上7:06，就在卡洛塔回家并发现米格尔不在家的时候。亚历山大告诉米格尔他搞到了一些大麻，邀请他稍后和另外两个男孩一起抽。其中一个男孩叫杰罗。米格尔刚开始吸大麻，他的母亲和姐姐甚至不知道他试过这个。米格尔看起来很高兴也很惊讶，并回复了一条语音信息。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
That's Miguel. He's saying, oh, you're so bad. What have you done? At this point in the morning, Miguel was still with Carlota at the mall. It sounds like her in the background of some of these messages, talking and laughing.
那是米格尔。他说，噢，你太坏了。你干了什么？在那天的那个时候，米格尔还和卡洛塔在购物中心。背景里听起来像是她，在说话和笑。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Miguel says he wants to bring along a friend, but Alexander says, no, don't do that. Jairo won't like it. Jairo's going to hook them up with weed. Later, Miguel and Alexander argue about whether to meet in the woods or at Miguel's house. Miguel tells Alexander that he'd prefer to meet at his house because he doesn't like to go out into the trees. But finally, Miguel gives in and agrees to meet in the woods near the high school, a few blocks away from his house. The last message is from Alexander.
米格尔说他想带一个朋友，但亚历山大说，不，别那样做。杰罗会不喜欢的。杰罗会帮他们搞到大麻。后来，米格尔和亚历山大争论是在树林里见面还是在米格尔家里。米格尔告诉亚历山大他更愿意在家里见面，因为他不喜欢去树林里。但最终，米格尔屈服了，同意在靠近高中、离他家几个街区的树林里见面。最后一条信息是亚历山大发的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He tells Miguel he's by the fluorescent lights already, at the school. He seems annoyed that Miguel isn't there yet. And then, nothing. In the days and months after that night, Miguel's Facebook account is flooded with messages from family and friends wondering where he is, or vowing to find him. But none of those messages was from Alexander Lokote.
他告诉米格尔他已经在学校的荧光灯旁了。他似乎对米格尔还没到感到恼火。然后，就没有然后了。在那天晚上之后的日子和几个月里，米格尔的Facebook账号被家人和朋友询问他下落或誓要找到他的信息淹没。但这些信息中没有一条来自亚历山大·洛科特。
Abraham showed all these Facebook messages to Detective Perez. Carlota said soon afterward, the detective called with a strange suggestion. He asked Abraham and Carlota if they wanted to meet him at the high school. He said he was going to interview Alexander Lokote in the principal's office, to see what he might know. And for some reason, he wanted to give them a chance to be there for it. When they got to the high school, Alexander Lokote was there. Lady had been called out of class, and was waiting outside the office.
亚伯拉罕把这些Facebook信息都给了佩雷斯探员。卡洛塔说，不久之后，侦探打来电话，提出了一个奇怪的建议。他问亚伯拉罕和卡洛塔是否想在高中和他见面。他说他要在校长办公室面试亚历山大·洛科特，看看他可能知道些什么。不知为何，他想给他们一个机会在现场。当他们到达高中时，亚历山大·洛科特就在那。莱迪被从课堂叫出来，在办公室外等待。
What did Alexander look like?
亚历山大长什么样？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He was scared.
他很害怕。
Scared how?
怎么个害怕法？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He looked kind of pale, and as though he wanted to get out of there right away.
他看起来脸色发白，好像想立刻逃离那里。
Did Alexander dress like a gang member?
亚历山大穿得像帮派成员吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Yeah, he was dressed like a gang member. He was wearing his white long t-shirt.
是，他穿得像帮派成员。他穿着那件白色长T恤。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And I saw the rosary.
我还看到了念珠。
What color rosary?
什么颜色的念珠？
Blue.
蓝色。
I ran this episode past a few police experts. And they all said it was really odd that Detective Perez invited the victim's family to an interrogation of a witness or a potential suspect like that. For one thing, it could make it harder to use anything Alexander said that day to build the case in court. They said that if Detective Perez suspected foul play at that point, he should have gotten a warrant to search Alexander's phone.
我把这一集内容拿给几位警察专家看。他们都说佩雷斯探员邀请受害者家属参加对证人或潜在嫌疑人的审讯真的很奇怪。一方面，这可能使在法庭上使用亚历山大那天说的任何话来建立案件变得更加困难。他们说，如果佩雷斯探员当时怀疑有刑事犯罪，他本应申请搜查亚历山大手机的搜查令。
Abraham thought that Alexander looked young, and so weak that he couldn't break a plate. He said that Alexander told him that he, Jairo, and another kid, had planned to go with Miguel to some train tracks. But Miguel never showed up. Carlota told Abraham that so far, her teenage daughter seemed to have made more progress than the detectives.
亚伯拉罕认为亚历山大看起来很年轻，虚弱得连个盘子都摔不碎。他说亚历山大告诉他，他和杰罗以及另一个孩子原计划和米格尔去铁轨附近，但米格尔从未出现。卡洛塔告诉亚伯拉罕，到目前为止，她十几岁的女儿似乎比侦探们取得了更大的进展。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
This was such a key thing that he knows. What else do they want? They weren't doing anything.
这是他知道的关键线索，他们还需要什么？他们什么都没做。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's not clear what happened to Alexander Lokote. Lady tells me that after this meeting, she stopped seeing him in school. I've been trying to find Alexander for months, but nobody I've talked to knows his real last name.
不清楚亚历山大·洛科特发生了什么。莱迪告诉我，在那次会议后，她就没在学校见过他。我已经试着找亚历山大好几个月了，但我谈过的每个人都不知道他真正的姓氏。
Carlota stopped going to her job at an envelope factory. She spent most of her time in her basement apartment looking through Miguel's clothes, breathing in their smell, and trying to distract herself by reading romance novels.
卡洛塔停止了在信封厂的工作。她大部分时间都待在地下室公寓里，翻看米格尔的衣服，呼吸它们上面的味道，并试图通过阅读浪漫小说来分散自己的注意力。
She hated when Lady went out, even to attend church. Nearly three months after Miguel disappeared, at the end of April, the state finally gave Carlota a missing person poster. The poster read, quote, "Miguel is a runaway." Then one afternoon in May, Carlota was watching the news at home when she saw another mother on TV, crying.
她讨厌莱迪出门，哪怕是去教堂。米格尔失踪近三个月后，4月底，州政府终于给了卡洛塔一张失踪人员海报。海报上写着，引用：“米格尔是离家出走。”然后5月的一个下午，卡洛塔在家里看新闻时，看到电视上另一位母亲在哭泣。
Oscar Acosta disappeared two weeks ago. Police believe it's suspicious.
奥斯卡·阿科斯塔两周前失踪了。警方认为情况可疑。
Oscar Acosta, was a 19-year-old, weeks away from graduating high school. He had emigrated from El Salvador to Brentwood three years before. He left home to play soccer one night and hadn't been seen since. When Oscar's mother went to the police station, this may sound familiar to you, she had a hard time finding an officer who spoke Spanish. So she enlisted her cousin, and a woman from church, to help her talk to the officers. She felt that the police were ignoring the case, so she started posting handmade missing person flyers, just as Carlota had.
奥斯卡·阿科斯塔是一个19岁的年轻人，距离高中毕业仅剩几周。他三年前从萨尔瓦多移民到布伦特伍德。他那天晚上出门踢足球，就再也没有露面。当奥斯卡的母亲去警察局时，这对你来说可能很耳熟，她很难找到一个会说西班牙语的警官。所以她招募了她的堂兄和一位教堂的女士来帮她与警官交谈。她觉得警方忽略了这个案子，于是她开始像卡洛塔一样张贴手工制作的失踪人员传单。
In June, a third Brentwood high school student went missing, Jose Pena. He was 18 years old. Emigrated from El Salvador two years before, like Oscar. Jose's mother didn't speak English either. When she went to the police station, she also says there was no one who spoke Spanish. So she had to ask her cab driver to interpret for her. He charged her $70. The police told her not to worry. Her son was probably hanging out with friends. He'd be back soon.
6月，第三名布伦特伍德高中的学生失踪了，何塞·佩纳。他18岁。和奥斯卡一样，两年前从萨尔瓦多移民而来。何塞的母亲也不会说英语。当她去警察局时，她说也没有会说西班牙语的人。所以她不得不请求她的出租车司机为她翻译。他收了她70美元。警方告诉她不必担心，她儿子可能只是和朋友出去了，很快就会回来。
Oscar and Jose were not minors, so they couldn't be listed as runaways. Police put out a press release on Oscar's disappearance two weeks after he went missing. They never said anything about Jose. These mothers have told me that it seems to them like police were either uninterested in helping them, or unable to do their jobs. They said it seemed like they were being brushed off because they were immigrants.
奥斯卡和何塞不是未成年人，所以他们不能被列为离家出走。警方在奥斯卡失踪两周后发布了一份关于他失踪的新闻稿。关于何塞，他们什么都没说。这些母亲告诉我，在她们看来，警方要么是不想帮助她们，要么就是没有能力做好工作。她们说，看起来她们因为是移民而被冷落了。
The Suffolk County Police Department wouldn't comment on any of the specifics of what happened with these families. They wouldn't comment about why they incorrectly classified all these disappearances as runaways. But they did send this statement, quote, "Our response to a reported missing person does not differ based on nationality or ethnicity." They also said, quote, "Suffolk County Police officers are among the finest in the country and treat everyone with professionalism and compassion."
萨福克县警察局拒绝就这些家庭遭遇的具体细节发表评论，拒绝评论为什么他们错误地将所有这些失踪案分类为离家出走。但他们发了一份声明，引用：“我们对失踪人员报告的反应不会因国籍或种族而有任何不同。”他们还说，引用：“萨福克县警官是全国最优秀的，并以专业精神和同情心对待每一个人。”
But the mothers in these cases aren't just being oversensitive. The Department of Justice investigated the Suffolk County Police Department for two years, and in 2011, issued its observations. It documents a pattern of discrimination against Latinos. A former DOJ official said the department was both over and under policing Latino residents. Stopping them more frequently than white people for minor violations, while also failing to fully look into the crimes they reported. The DOJ called out the department for the exact problems Carlota and the other parents had told me about-- not enough Spanish speakers, not doing enough to protect Latino teenagers from gangs, and not taking Latino victims seriously, even treating them like suspects.
但这些案件中的母亲并不是过于敏感。司法部对萨福克县警察局进行了两年的调查，并于2011年发布了观察报告。它记录了对拉丁裔歧视的模式。一位前司法部官员表示，该部门对拉丁裔居民既存在过度执法又存在监管不足，因轻微违规拦截他们的频率比白人高，同时又没能充分调查他们报告的犯罪。司法部批评该部门存在卡洛塔和其他家长告诉我的确切问题——没有足够的西班牙语口译人员，没能充分保护拉丁裔青少年免受帮派侵害，没能认真对待拉丁裔受害者，甚至把他们当作嫌疑人对待。
The police department agreed to federal oversight until the bias issues were fixed. But seven years after the DOJ investigation ended, they're still finding the same problems. Because of the nature of the agreement, it's not overseen by a court. There isn't much the DOJ can do beyond issuing progress reports every year.
警察局同意接受联邦监管直到偏见问题得到解决。但在司法部调查结束七年之后，他们依然面临同样的问题。由于协议的性质，它不受法院监督。司法部除了每年发布进展报告外，能做的事情并不多。
In the midst of the disappearances of these three boys, another Brentwood high school student went missing. A 15-year-old girl from El Salvador, whose family asked that I not use her name. But unlike Miguel, Oscar, and Jose, after 2 and 1/2 days, her father found her just walking on the street by a White Castle. She said she'd been with some older boys. Her father couldn't figure out if she'd gone with them willingly, or if she'd been kidnapped. But something seemed wrong to him. His daughter wasn't acting normally. He thought maybe she had been drugged, possibly raped. And she'd just gotten some threatening text messages.
在这三名男孩失踪期间，另一名布伦特伍德高中的学生失踪了。一个来自萨尔瓦多的15岁女孩，她的家人要求我不要使用她的名字。但与米格尔、奥斯卡和何塞不同，2天半后，她的父亲发现她在快餐店附近步行。她说她和一些大男孩在一起。她的父亲无法弄清楚她是自愿去的，还是被绑架了。但对他来说，有些事情显得不对劲。他的女儿行为不正常。他认为她可能被下药了，可能被强奸了。而且她刚收到了一些威胁短信。
So as soon as they found her, he and his wife took her to the Suffolk County Police Department to ask them to investigate. The girl's father had been a cop in El Salvador, and ever since she'd gone missing, he'd been having trouble getting the police to take her disappearance seriously. So he and his wife secretly videotaped the meeting.
所以他们一找到她，他和妻子就带她去萨福克县警察局请求调查。女孩的父亲曾是萨尔瓦多的一名警察，自从她失踪以来，他一直难以让警方认真对待她的失踪案。所以他和妻子偷偷录下了这次会面。
OK. And what did you do?
好的。你做了什么？
I left.
我离开了。
With?
跟谁？
Watching the video, you can see firsthand how two Suffolk County Police officers treat an immigrant family that's come in to report a crime. In the video, the girl is sitting at a desk across from a detective named Michael Cammarata, who's leaning back in his chair. The father's crouching on the floor. And immediately, Detective Cammarata begins interrogating the girl in English. As if she was the one who'd done something wrong. Instead of asking the 15-year-old girl about how she may have been hurt, Detective Cammarata threatens to throw her in juvenile detention, which is in Nassau County. He thinks she was lying about something. And she is being vague and evasive in her answers.
观看录像时，你可以亲眼看到两名萨福克县警察是如何对待一个来报案的移民家庭的。录像中，女孩坐在一位名叫迈克尔·卡马拉塔的侦探对面的一张桌子旁，侦探向后靠在椅子上。父亲蹲在地上。侦探卡马拉塔立即开始用英语盘问女孩，就好像她是做了错事的人。卡马拉塔侦探不是询问15岁的女孩她可能受到了怎样的伤害，而是威胁要把她关进少年拘留所，那是在拿骚县。他认为她在某件事上撒谎。而她在回答时含糊其辞。
Who were you with?
你和谁在一起？
[INAUDIBLE].
[听不清]。
They said you were with two boys. That's what Fanny said.
他们说你和两个男孩在一起。芬妮就是这么说的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. So you need to -- look, I don't-- do you not understand what I've been going through for the last two days trying to find you? OK. And how much trouble you could be in? It's up to me, whether or not I take you to Nassau County and you stay there. OK? Which just means, it's just you and I. Not your family. I take you. I put handcuffs on you. And I take you. OK? So you need to tell me who you were with. Who were the boys?
是的。所以你需要——听着，我不知道——难道你不明白过去两天我为了找到你经历了什么吗？好的。你可能会惹上多大的麻烦？是否把你带到拿骚县由我决定。好的？那意味着只有你和我。不是你的家人。我带你。我给你戴上手铐。我带走你。好的？所以你需要告诉我你和谁在一起。那些男孩是谁？
The girl's dad doesn't speak English, but he can make out the details of what they're talking about. He hears a name he recognizes, and he can tell his daughter isn't giving the full story. He wants to jump in and help the cops. Give some information about an older guy she's been hanging out with. And he wants to understand and monitor the conversation between the detective and his 15-year-old daughter. So he asked the detective for an interpreter.
女孩的父亲不会说英语，但他能听懂他们谈话的细节。他听到了一个他认出的名字，他能看出女儿并没有说出实情。他想介入并帮助警察，提供一些关于她一直往来的大男孩的信息。他想理解并监控侦探和15岁女儿之间的对话。所以他向侦探请求翻译。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
OK.
好的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The detective ignores his request, which is technically a violation of federal civil rights laws. A minute later, the girl's dad asks again.
侦探无视了他的请求，这在技术上违反了联邦民权法。一分钟后，女孩的父亲再次请求。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
He said that too.
他也这么说了。
Another 2 and 1/2 minutes pass with no interpreter. So the girl's dad asks her to translate his request to the detective.
又过了2分半钟，还是没有翻译。所以女孩的父亲让她把他的请求翻译给侦探。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Well, he said he needed an interpreter.
嗯，他说他需要一个翻译。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
So he can inform you of everything.
这样他就能通知你一切。
So he can inform me?
这样他能通知我？
No. So he can tell you everything. Because he doesn't speak that much English.
不。这样他能告诉你一切。因为他英语说得不好。
The girl's dad actually starts leaving the room to try to find an interpreter himself. The detective tells him to stay put.
女孩的父亲实际上正要离开房间试图自己找翻译。侦探告诉他待在原地。
Tell him he has to stay.
告诉他他必须留在这。
Finally, as the detective continues interrogating the girl, the dad takes out his cell phone and calls a community advocate he knows. He passes the phone over to the detective.
最终，当侦探继续盘问女孩时，父亲拿出手机给认识的一个社区倡导者打了电话。他把手机递给了侦探。
Hello?
喂？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
This is Carlos, I need interpreter, no understand.
我是卡洛斯，我需要翻译，听不懂。
OK. What is he want me to interpret?
好的。他想让我翻译什么？
The guy on the phone repeats what the dad has been saying, that he needs an interpreter. And the detective agrees to get another officer who speaks Spanish.
电话里的人重复了父亲一直在说的话，说他需要翻译。侦探同意叫另一名会说西班牙语的警官来。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
OK. All right. I'm just going to use an officer. I just wanted to make sure what he was looking for.
好的。行。我就用一名警官。我只是想确认他在找什么。
He said, I wanted to make sure what he was looking for. Though it seems like the dad has made that pretty clear.
他说，我只是想确认他在找什么。尽管看起来父亲已经说得很清楚了。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
OK. All right.
好的。行。
The detective hands the phone back to him, and he goes right back to interrogating the girl--
侦探把手机还给了他，然后又回到用英语盘问女孩——
All right. So you're with Carlos. Who else is in the house with Carlos?
行。所以你和卡洛斯在一起。房子里还有谁和卡洛斯在一起？
--in English.
——用英语。
Just Carlos.
只有卡洛斯。
Six minutes go by, the dad asks for an interpreter for the seventh time. And finally, the detective goes out to get one.
六分钟过去了，父亲第七次要求翻译。最终，侦探出去叫了一名翻译。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Here he returns with another detective, who speaks Spanish.
他带着另一名会说西班牙语的侦探回来了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Si, senor.
是的，先生。
[SPEAKING SPANISH] OK.
[说西班牙语]好的。
It's Detective Perez. The same guy Carlota has been dealing with. The dad starts explaining the whole saga in Spanish, but Perez cuts him off. He turns to the girl and asks if she speaks English. She says she does.
是佩雷斯探员。就是卡洛塔一直打交道的那个人。父亲开始用西班牙语解释整个事情的来龙去脉，但佩雷斯打断了他。他转向女孩，问她是否会说英语。她说会。
Now, you speak English. You speak English?
好了，你会说英语。你会说英语吗？
The dad jumps in and asks Perez to speak in Spanish.
父亲介入并要求佩雷斯用西班牙语说话。
He doesn't speak Spanish, so if you speak English, you speak English.
他不回说西班牙语，所以如果你会说英语，你就说英语。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Perez Ignores her dad and begins interrogating the daughter in English.
佩雷斯无视她的父亲，开始用英语盘问女儿。
You think that we're as dumb as the kids you hang out with?
你以为我们和你那些混在一起的孩子一样蠢吗？
He tells the girl she's lying. And like the other detective, he threatens to lock her up in juvie.
他告诉女孩她在撒谎。和另一位侦探一样，他威胁要把她关进少年管教所。
How about instead of going back with your parents, we bring you to the Nassau County juvenile facility, to jail? Because you're a juvenile delinquent by law. You know what that means? That you don't follow the rules, we can bring you to a juvenile jail. And you just stay there, until your parents are ready to get you.
与其和你父母回去，不如我们把你带到拿骚县的少年设施，去监狱怎么样？因为根据法律你是少年犯。你知道那意味着什么吗？意味着如果你不守规矩，我们可以把你带到少年监狱。你就待在那里，直到你父母准备好接你。
The interrogation gets more intense. Detective Cammarata threatens to take the girl to a hospital and do tests on her to see what she's been up to with these older guys. The 15-year-old hangs her head and explains to her mom in tears what the detectives have been saying. She says the officers are accusing her of lying. She says she doesn't want them to arrest her and deport her.
盘问变得更加激烈。卡马拉塔侦探威胁要把女孩带到医院做检查，看她和那些大男孩在一起干了什么。15岁的女孩低着头，含着泪向母亲解释了侦探们说的话。她说警官在指控她撒谎。她说她不希望他们逮捕她并把她驱逐出境。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
The girl did give them one of the names of the guys she was with. The detectives, as far as I can tell, don't use it as a lead. Instead, Detective Perez goes into this whole scared straight speech with her. He tells her to stop hanging out with these guys. And if she doesn't, he'll go after them, and then they'll be mad at her.
女孩确实给了他们其中一个和她在一起的男人的名字。据我所知，侦探们并没有把它当作线索来用。相反，佩雷斯探员对她进行了这一整套“恐吓教育”演讲。他告诉她不要再和那些人鬼混。如果她不听，他就会去对付他们，然后他们会因为她把他们置于这种境地而对她感到愤怒。
We have ways of going into old messages. We'll find this guy you were with. We'll lock him up. We'll then lock everybody up that they end up hating you for you putting them in this position. You're a young girl. Stay away from these older guys, because you'll only get them in trouble. OK?
我们有办法查看旧信息。我们会找到和你在一起的那个家伙。我们会把他关起来。然后我们会把所有因为你置他们于此地而恨你的家伙都关起来。你是个年轻女孩。远离那些大男孩，因为你只会让他们惹上麻烦。好的？
Instead of taking the girl's parents' concerns seriously, or even hearing them out in their own language, Detective Perez threatens their daughter. And her parents had good reason to be concerned. Their daughter told me that she had spent the days with an MS-13 gang member, who a year later would be charged with four murders.
佩雷斯探员不仅没有认真对待女孩父母的担忧，甚至连用他们自己的语言听听他们的诉求都没有，反而威胁了他们的女儿。而她的父母确实有充分的理由感到担忧。女儿告诉我，她确实和一名MS-13帮派成员待了几天，该成员一年后因四起谋杀案被指控。
Nine months later, the girl went missing again. She came home again, and this time she seemed genuinely scared. Her father called the police to ask once more if the officers would investigate the guy she'd been with. He says they came over, talked to the girl, said they'd be in touch, and never were.
九个月后，女孩再次失踪。她又回家了，这次她看起来真的很害怕。她的父亲打电话给警察再次询问警官是否会调查她在一起的那个人。他说他们来了，和女孩谈了谈，说会保持联系，但从未兑现。
It's unclear if they investigated beyond that. If they did investigate, they might have learned that she'd been with the leader of one of the MS-13 cliques, a guy who's now charged with six counts of murder.
不清楚他们除了那次之外是否还进行了调查。如果他们调查了，他们可能会发现她一直和MS-13的一个分支头目在一起，那个家伙现在被指控犯有六项谋杀罪。
Hannah Dreier. Coming up, all those cops you've been hearing about all this hour? Hannah asks their boss, what the hell? That's in a minute, when our program continues.
汉娜·德雷尔。接下来的内容，所有你们这一个小时里听到的那些警察？汉娜要问他们的老板，到底是怎么回事？节目继续，稍后回来。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "The Runaways," investigative reporter Hannah Dreier from ProPublica is telling the story of a string of murders of immigrant teenagers in Long Island by the gang MS-13 that, for months and months, it seemed like the Suffolk County Police were not treating as murders, and certainly did not solve.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“离家出走者”，来自ProPublica的调查记者汉娜·德雷尔正在讲述关于长岛一群移民少年被帮派MS-13谋杀的故事，几个月来，萨福克县警方似乎并没有把这些案件当作谋杀案来对待，当然也根本没破案。
When families reported their children missing, police told them that their kids were fine. They chose to ignore leads and evidence the parents offered, didn't follow procedures and best practices that other police departments follow in similar cases. And they listed the children as runaways, which had effects on how rigorous the investigations were.
当家庭报告孩子失踪时，警方告诉他们孩子很好。他们选择忽略父母提供的线索和证据，没有遵循其他警察部门在类似案件中遵循的程序和最佳实践。他们将孩子列为离家出走，这影响了调查的严格程度。
The families believe they were treated this way because they're all Spanish-speaking immigrants. So Hannah sat down with Timothy Sini. He was the Suffolk County Police commissioner from 2016 to the beginning of 2018. Basically, he was in charge of the cops during these cases-- to see how he explained this police behavior. Here's Hannah.
这些家庭认为他们被这样对待是因为他们都是讲西班牙语的移民。所以汉娜与蒂莫西·西尼（Timothy Sini）坐下来聊了聊。他从2016年到2018年初担任萨福克县警察局长。基本上，他在这些案件期间负责这些警察——看看他如何解释这种警察行为。汉娜采访的内容如下。
When people on Long Island talk about Timothy Sini, they talk about him as a future congressman or New York attorney general. Sometimes, they say it in an earnest way, because he's clean cut, with some movie star sparkle, a heavy square jaw, and a diploma from the Harvard Kennedy School of Government, a Democratic Golden Boy in Trump Country.
当长岛的人谈论蒂莫西·西尼时，他们把他称为未来的国会议员或纽约州总检察长。有时，他们会认真地说，因为他形象干练，带着明星般的光彩，有着厚实的方下巴，拥有哈佛肯尼迪政府学院的学位，是特朗普地盘上的民主党“金童”。
Sometimes, they say it with an eye roll, because Timothy Sini is a professional politician who revels in media attention, who has been known to hold press conferences to talk about Halloween safety, and who appears to be swinging through short stints in New York institutions with his eye on bigger things.
有时，他们会带着反感的眼光说，因为蒂莫西·西尼是一个热衷于媒体关注的职业政治家，他曾被曝为讨论万圣节安全而举行新闻发布会，他似乎在纽约的机构中短暂轮岗，眼光瞄准了更高的位置。
Sini worked his way through the US attorney's office and the Long Island County Executive's office to become the youngest ever head of the Suffolk County Police Department, at the age of 36. Today, he's no longer the police commissioner. Last year, he was elected to be the Suffolk County District Attorney. One of his campaign slogans was "the man who took MS-13 down."
西尼通过在联邦检察官办公室和长岛县长办公室的工作，在36岁时成为了萨福克县警察局有史以来最年轻的局长。今天，他不再是警察局长。去年，他当选为萨福克县地方检察官。他竞选的口号之一是“击败MS-13的人”。
We sat in a conference room at a beautiful dark wood table. Government buildings are unusually nice in Suffolk County. And I asked him about the immigrant boys who went missing in 2016.
我们在一个漂亮的深色木桌会议室里坐下。萨福克县的政府大楼异常漂亮。我问了他关于2016年失踪的那些移民男孩的情况。
Part of what we're writing about is the kids who went missing during that time. And I noticed that--
我们写的内容的一部分是关于当时失踪的孩子。我注意到——
What time?
什么时间？
During, like, 2016, 2017.
在2016年、2017年左右。
What kids went missing in 2016, 2017?
2016年、2017年有哪几个孩子失踪了？
Oscar Acosta.
奥斯卡·阿科斯塔。
No, that's before then.
不，那是那之前的事。
No, they all went missing in 2016. Miguel Garcia. That was all 2016.
不，他们都在2016年失踪的。米格尔·加西亚。那都是2016年的事。
No, it was 2015.
不，那是2015年。
No, no, no. It was definitely 2016.
不，不，不。那绝对是2016年。
I would have to double check.
我得核实一下。
This is an important distinction, because if they had happened in 2015, which they didn't, that would have been before Timothy Sini took over the department.
这是一个重要的区别，因为如果发生在2015年，事实并非如此，那将在蒂莫西·西尼接管部门之前。
I guess, like--
我想，就像——
But they went missing in 2015.
但他们是2015年失踪的。
OK. I mean--
好吧。我的意思是——
Right? I mean, we can just check.
对吧？我的意思是，我们可以查一下。
I don't know.
我不知道。
Yeah, we can just check the records.
是的，我们可以查记录。
Yeah, do you wanna Google that?
是的，你想去谷歌一下吗？
I mean, I could be-- well, don't Google it. Check, like, real records.
我的意思是，我可能是——好吧，别谷歌。查一查真正的记录。
On?
查什么？
Like a missing persons report.
像失踪人口报告。
Yeah, I mean, it's on--
是的，我的意思是，它就在——
Right. Google?
对。谷歌？
It's reported. That was all reported.
它有报道。那些都有报道。
Oh, I don't go based on reports.
噢，我不根据报道做判断。
So you don't remember when they went missing, it sounds like.
听起来你记不清他们什么时候失踪的。
I don't have the exact date, but I can get it to you very easily.
我没有确切日期，但我可以很容易地给你。
OK. So anyway, when they went missing, their parents say that--
好吧。总之，当他们失踪时，他们的父母说——
You know, that's very important too. Because when I came in as police commissioner, we can get the exact dates and then lay out the whole chronology. But when I came as police commissioner--
你知道，那也很重要。因为当我接任警察局长时，我们可以得到确切日期并列出整个时间表。但当我接任警察局长时——
Here's the whole chronology. Timothy Sini took over the department in January 2016. Miguel went missing in February. The 15-year-old girl in the secret recording went missing and was found in March. Oscar went missing in April. Jose Pena went missing in June.
这是完整的时间表。蒂莫西·西尼于2016年1月接管了该部门。米格尔在2月失踪。秘密录音中那个15岁的女孩在3月失踪并被找到。奥斯卡在4月失踪。何塞·佩纳在6月失踪。
Once we actually started talking about the missing kid cases, former police commissioner Sini immediately said something I hadn't heard from anyone. He said the police knew as soon as the boys disappeared that they were murder victims, not runaways, not just missing people.
一旦我们真正开始讨论失踪儿童案件，前警察局长西尼立即说了一些我没从任何人那里听到的内容。他说警方在男孩们失踪时就知道他们是谋杀受害者，而不是离家出走，不仅仅是失踪人口。
But when I came as police commissioner, we had some missing boys, right? And right away, Chief Giganti, Gerard Giganti, who I promoted to chief detective, came to me and said, "I don't think these boys are missing. I believe they're homicide victims. I believe they're victims of MS-13 gang violence."
但当我接任警察局长时，我们有几个失踪男孩，对吧？杰拉德·吉甘蒂（Gerard Giganti）——我提拔的首席侦探——立刻找到我说：“我不认为这些男孩只是失踪了。我相信他们是凶杀受害者。我相信他们是MS-13帮派暴力的受害者。”
When did he say that?
他什么时候那么说的？
Basically, as soon as I was told that we had missing boys, that was his analysis.
基本上一告诉我有男孩失踪，这就是他的分析。
So you were told these three boys were missing. We suspect they're homicides.
所以有人告诉你有三个男孩失踪了，我们怀疑是凶杀案。
There's no question about that. They were likely homicide victims. No doubt about it, right out of the gate.
那毫无疑问。他们很可能是凶杀受害者。这一点毋庸置疑，一开始就是这样。
So when you first came in.
所以当你刚来的时候。
When I first-- I have to look at when they were reported missing for the fifth time, OK?
当我也刚——我得看看他们第5次被报失踪是什么时候，好吧？
OK, I mean, I'm telling you--
好的，我的意思是，我在告诉你——
But I'm telling you that right out of the gate, we suspected they were homicides.
但我告诉你，一开始我们就怀疑他们是凶杀受害者。
This was nuts to me, because the police appeared to be treating so many of the kids as runaways, were telling their parents not to worry, that they'd come home soon.
这对我来说太疯狂了，因为警方似乎把这么多孩子当作离家出走对待，告诉他们的父母不要担心，他们很快就会回家。
So the first one, Miguel Moran, he was missing, and he was listed as a runaway for-- he was listed, like, three times as a runaway. He went missing in February.
所以第一个，米格尔·莫兰，他失踪了，并且被列为离家出走——他被列了三次离家出走。他在2月失踪的。
There may have been several times he went missing.
他可能失踪了好几次。
No, he went missing once, in February. And then he was listed as a runaway.
不，他只失踪了一次，在2月。然后他就被列为了离家出走。
So I am not going to sit here and debate with you facts about when someone went missing. We will pull the missing persons report.
我不会坐在这里和你争论一个人什么时候失踪的事实。我们会调出失踪人员报告的。
I mean, I can show you here.
我的意思是，我可以给你看这里。
I don't care what article you're showing me.
我不在乎你给我看什么文章。
It's just, like-- it's the date, February 2016. I have the-- I think I might even have the missing persons.
只是，就像——日期是2016年2月。我有——我想我甚至可能有失踪人员的记录。
OK, so February 2016. That may be right on that particular one. So he goes missing in February 2016, which is a few months after I get in. Gerry Giganti, out of the gate, says that this is not a missing persons. It is a homicide. Which is why we transferred the missing persons case from the general squad. Typically, it's a general squad investigation. We transfer it immediately to the major case squad.
好吧，所以是2016年2月。那在那个特定的案件上可能是对的。所以他在2016年2月失踪，那是在我上任几个月后。杰瑞·吉甘蒂从一开始就说这不是失踪人口。这是一起凶杀案。这就是为什么我们将失踪人员案件从普通中队调出。通常，那是普通中队调查的。我们立即将其移交给了重案组。
So in Miguel's case, he went missing in February, and then this is the poster that the family was given. This is now two months later, in April. And again, it says Miguel is a runaway. So he seems, at least from the outside, like he was listed as a runaway.
所以米格尔的案件，他在2月失踪，然后这是家人得到的传单。这已经是两个月后的4月了。同样，上面写着米格尔是离家出走。所以他看起来，至少从外部看，像被列为离家出走。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
And the police told at least the state that he was a runaway. And that happened again with all the boys.
而且警方至少告诉州政府他是离家出走。所有的男孩都再次发生了这种情况。
Yeah, it's information that they probably received from the person filing the missing persons report.
是的，这些信息可能是他们从报案的人那里收到的。
In other words, Miguel's family.
换句话说，是米格尔的家人。
Just because--
仅仅因为——
No, the person was convinced that he was not a runaway.
不，那个报案人深信他不是离家出走。
I don't know the source of the runaway component. I don't know where the runaway part came from. I don't know if it came from someone in the family. I don't know if it came from another witness. I don't know if it came from a friend of the boy. But there is no question that, internally, there's no doubt that the Suffolk County Police Department, essentially out of the gate, believed that there was foul play.
我不知道离家出走部分的消息来源。我不知道离家出走的部分来自哪里。我不知道是来自家人，还是来自其他证人，或者是男孩的朋友。但毫无疑问，在内部，萨福克县警察局从一开始就认为发生了刑事犯罪。
This is, of course, at odds with the press release the Suffolk County Police put out after Miguel disappeared, which said, quote, "Detectives do not believe there is foul play involved in Moran's disappearance."
这当然与萨福克县警方在米格尔失踪后发布的新闻稿相矛盾，该稿件称，引用：“侦探们不认为莫兰的失踪涉及刑事犯罪。”
Timothy Sini said he wasn't aware of any policy about listing a kid as a runaway instead of as a missing person. I wanted to know why the Suffolk County Police Department's rules and procedures had so little to say about what to do if a kid goes missing. Just two paragraphs compared to much more detailed guidelines and checklists in Nassau County and New York City.
蒂莫西·西尼说他不知道有什么政策将孩子列为离家出走而不是失踪人口。我想知道为什么萨福克县警察局的规则和程序对孩子失踪该怎么做提及得如此之少。与拿骚县和纽约市更详细的指导方针和清单相比，只有两段话。
Former Commissioner Sini said he didn't know what I was talking about, so I showed him a copy of that section, which I had with me.
前局长西尼说他不知道我在说什么，所以我给他看了那部分的副本，我随身带着。
Basically, there are two paragraphs. One says--
基本上有两段。一段说——
I understand what you said. And I said I think there is actually more to it. And I think maybe, depending-- I don't know if we can get that to you, because that would essentially reveal investigative steps, but--
我理解你说的。我认为实际上还有更多内容。我想可能，根据——我不知道我们能否把它给你，因为那本质上会揭露调查步骤，但——
There's more to it? Like, more in the rules and procedures?
还有更多内容？比如，规则和程序里有更多内容？
Yes, I believe there--
是的，我相信有——
I mean, these are the rules and procedures.
我的意思是，这就是规则和程序。
I can assure you that these are not the rules and procedures of the Suffolk County Police Department. The rules the procedures of the Suffolk County Police Department are about 5,000 pages long.
我可以向你保证，这些不是萨福克县警察局的规则和程序。萨福克县警察局的规则和程序大约有5000页长。
They're 1,602 pages long. I have a copy. The Police Department's press office pointed out to me that if a child goes missing, the rules and procedures include another way they can find him or her. There are a few paragraphs about the statewide missing person alert system and how to request an alert. But the police never did that for Miguel, or the 15-year-old girl, or Oscar, or Jose.
它们有1602页。我有一份副本。警察局新闻办公室向我指出，如果孩子失踪，规则和程序包括另一种他们可以找到他或她的方法。有几段关于全州失踪人员警报系统以及如何申请警报的内容。但警方从未为米格尔、那个15岁的女孩、奥斯卡或何塞做过这些。
The press office also said that police officers learn how to deal with missing children in more detail during their training. The rules and procedures also say that police officers have to provide free Spanish language interpretation for anyone whose primary language is not English. And the agreement with the Department of Justice says that police have to use interpretation services instead of forcing Spanish speakers to rely on their children or hire their taxi drivers. I asked Timothy Sini about the mom who told me she did just that.
新闻办公室还表示，警官在培训期间更详细地学习了如何处理失踪儿童。规则和程序还规定，警官必须为任何主要语言不是英语的人提供免费的西班牙语口译服务。与司法部的协议也规定，警察必须使用口译服务，而不是强迫说西班牙语的人依靠他们的孩子或雇佣他们的出租车司机。我问蒂莫西·西尼关于那位告诉我她正是这样做的母亲的事。
So we have a contract with Language Line, which is part of our language access plan.
所以我们与Language Line签了合同，这是我们语言访问计划的一部分。
Great, so I wonder why it wasn't used.
太好了，所以我奇怪为什么没用它。
Can you not interrupt me? So listen. So we have a contract with language access. If there is a--
你能别打断我吗？听着。所以我们有语言访问合同。如果有一个——
Language Line is a service where police can call an interpreter on the phone if there's no one available in the office. Police tell me it can be a hassle to use. Also, the connections can be bad, with dropped calls and annoyingly bad sound quality. I asked Former Commissioner Sini about the 15-year-old girl's experience, the one that was caught on the recording, and how many times the detectives refused to speak with her father in Spanish. But he said he wouldn't respond to, quote, "bald allegations."
Language Line是一项服务，如果办公室里没人，警察可以通过电话呼叫翻译。警察告诉我使用它可能很麻烦。而且连接可能很差，通话中断，音质令人恼火地糟糕。我问前局长西尼关于15岁女孩的经历，就是录音里捕捉到的那个，以及侦探们多少次拒绝与她的父亲用西班牙语交谈。但他表示不会回应所谓“未经证实的指控”。
The Suffolk County Police tell me they've improved. They say they now have 10 certified interpreters, up from three. But according to the most recent DOJ report, from March, they're still not regularly using professional interpreters. The report says that when non-English speakers call the department, they are only given interpretation services 20% of the time. And the department is still letting officers use bilingual children as crime scene interpreters, even though the DOJ keeps saying that that should be banned.
萨福克县警方告诉我他们已经改进了。他们说他们现在有10名认证翻译，高于之前的3名。但根据3月份最新的司法部报告，他们仍然没有经常使用专业翻译。报告称，当非英语母语者拨打该部门电话时，他们只有20%的时间得到口译服务。该部门仍然允许警官使用双语儿童作为犯罪现场翻译，尽管司法部不断表示那应该被禁止。
I recently talked to a 12-year-old girl whose brother was attacked by MS-13 in the woods by their house. The gang cut off his hand with a machete. When the police came to interview him, they asked her to interpret for him. She told me that after she heard her brother tell all the details of the attack, she didn't want to leave the house anymore.
我最近和一名12岁的女孩谈过，她的兄弟在房子旁边的树林里遭到MS-13的袭击。帮派用砍刀砍下了他的手。当警察来采访他时，他们让她为他翻译。她告诉我，在她听到兄弟讲述袭击的所有细节后，她再也不想离开家了。
Everyone, former Commissioner Sini included, agrees on one thing-- what led to the boys being found, and their cases being investigated more rigorously-- were the next MS-13 attacks, the double murder of two teenage girls, Kayla Cuevas and Nisa Mickens.
每个人，包括前局长西尼，在一件事上达成共识——导致男孩被找到、他们的案件得到更严格调查的是随后的MS-13袭击，即两名少女凯拉·奎瓦斯（Kayla Cuevas）和妮莎·米肯斯（Nisa Mickens）的双重谋杀案。
In September, seven months after Miguel disappeared, best friends Kayla and Nisa were walking on a quiet street near Kayla's home, when a group of boys they'd been feuding with at school jumped out of a car and attacked them. They used baseball bats and machetes. The attackers left 15-year-old Nisa's mangled body right there on the street. 16-year-old Kayla was missing overnight. The next day, a neighbor found her body in a patch of woods on the same block. Almost immediately, the full force of the Suffolk County Police Department kicked into gear.
9月，在米格尔失踪七个月后，好朋友凯拉和妮莎正走在凯拉家附近一条安静的街道上，一群她们在学校一直有纠纷的男孩跳下一辆车攻击了她们。他们使用了棒球棍和砍刀。袭击者把15岁的妮莎那面目全非的尸体留在了街上。16岁的凯拉失踪了一夜。第二天，邻居在同一街区的树林里发现了她的尸体。几乎立刻，萨福克县警察局全力出动。
And Maurice, police are calling the murders of these two teenage girls an act of savagery on this community, and they're asking for the public's help. They're also stepping up anti-gang enforcement they have at every level, they say, patrolling this neighborhood and Brentwood High School to find the killer or killers.
莫里斯，警方称这两名少女的谋杀案是对这个社区的残暴行为，他们正在寻求公众的帮助。他们也在各级加强反帮派执法，他们说，在这一社区和布伦特伍德高中巡逻以找到凶手或凶手们。
One obvious difference between the girl's deaths and the boys was that the police had the girls' bodies. The gang hadn't tried to hide them. But the boys' parents point out that the murders were different in another way. The boys were immigrants, from Spanish-speaking families. Kayla and Nisa, on the other hand, were girls born on Long Island, whose parents were English-speaking American citizens with nice homes and professional jobs.
女孩的死和男孩的一个明显区别在于警方拥有女孩的尸体。帮派没有试图隐藏它们。但男孩的父母指出，谋杀案在另一个方面是不同的。男孩是移民，来自讲西班牙语的家庭。而凯拉和妮莎，是出生在长岛的女孩，她们的父母是讲英语的美国公民，有漂亮的房子和专业工作。
Dozens of officers went door to door, asking for tips. The department increased patrols and posted flyers offering a cash reward of $15,000 for help catching the girls' killers. Police arrested 25 suspected MS-13 members and mapped out their cliques. Within days, officers were searching the woods with German Shepherds and shovels. A Suffolk County Detective visited Carlota at home and swabbed her teeth for DNA. Timothy Sini held press conferences.
数十名警察挨家挨户征求线索。该部门加强了巡逻，并张贴海报，悬赏1.5万美元帮助抓获杀害女孩的凶手。警方逮捕了25名嫌疑MS-13成员并绘制了他们的分支地图。几天之内，警官们就带着德国牧羊犬和铁锹搜查了树林。一名萨福克县侦探拜访了卡洛塔，提取了她的DNA样本。蒂莫西·西尼举行了新闻发布会。
We've made a strategic subject list of known gang members in the area. And we're going to be enhancing our presence here to target those individuals.
我们制定了一份该地区已知帮派成员的战略目标清单。我们将在这里加强我们的存在，以打击那些个人。
Lady was watching all of this play out.
莱迪一直在注视这一切发生。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
When Miguel and Oscar went missing, barely anyone would talk about it.
当米格尔和奥斯卡失踪时，几乎没人谈论它。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But then, when the girls were murdered, then everyone was talking about it.
但后来，当女孩们被谋杀时，每个人都在谈论它。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
But it was as though nobody could remember that there were some missing persons as well.
但似乎没人能记得还有一些失踪人员。
A few days after the girls were killed, Carlota was home watching Univision.
在女孩们被杀几天后，卡洛塔在家里看Univision电视台。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It was on TV that I learned when they found Oscar. And I just started to panic. Panic, panic, panic.
我是在电视上得知他们找到奥斯卡的。我开始恐慌。恐慌，恐慌，恐慌。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And my daughter said, no, Mom. But that's not Miguel. That's Oscar that they found. But I was panicking because I said, well, if they had found Oscar, then they practically found Miguel. And my daughter said, no, calm down. It's Oscar. It's not Miguel.
我的女儿说，不，妈妈。但那不是米格尔。他们找到的是奥斯卡。但我很恐慌，因为我说，好吧，如果他们找到了奥斯卡，那他们实际上就找到了米格尔。我的女儿说，不，冷静点。那是奥斯卡，不是米格尔。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Police had found Oscar's body in the woods, the ones they call the killing fields, near some train tracks. The reporter also said that another body had been found in the same place.
警方在树林里找到了奥斯卡的尸体，就是他们称之为杀戮场的地方，靠近一些铁轨。记者还说在同一个地方又发现了一具尸体。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And just then, through the window of the basement apartment, Carlota saw two men in suits coming down the stairs.
就在这时，通过地下室公寓的窗户，卡洛塔看到两个穿西装的人正走下楼梯。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I saw people coming in through the door. And when I saw that it was the same guy who came to take my DNA, I knew that they were here to give me some news.
我看到有人走进门。当我看到那是之前来提取我DNA的同一个人时，我就知道他们是来给我消息的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And I just-- I don't know. I just started to scream, and cry, and kneel, and just like I was dragging myself on the floor, because I knew why they were there.
我只是——我不知道。我只是开始尖叫、哭泣、下跪，就像我在地板上拖着自己，因为我知道他们为什么在那里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And then they left. And that's where I stopped remembering. It's like my mind was clouded.
然后他们离开了。我就在那停下了记忆。感觉我的心智被蒙蔽了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
And then, the next thing I knew, I woke up at the hospital.
然后，接下来的事我知道的就是我在医院醒来。
Carlota had run out of the apartment, tripped on some stairs outside, and smashed her face on the cement. The hospital staff wrote a summary on her chart. It said, quote, "altered mental state, patient repeatedly stating 'just kill me. My son, my son.'"
卡洛塔跑出公寓，在外面楼梯上绊倒，脸撞在了水泥地上。医院工作人员在她的病历上写了一份摘要，引用：“意识状态改变，病人反复说‘杀了我吧。我的儿子，我的儿子。’”
When she was released from the hospital, she packed Miguel's things, his clothes, video games, and school papers, into five trash bags and put them on the street. She felt guilty for having brought Miguel to Brentwood in the first place, for having told him to ignore the kids who were bothering him in school. When he was missing, Miguel's things had felt like a vital connection to someone who was alive, but now they seemed like recriminations.
当她从医院出院后，她把米格尔的东西，他的衣服、电子游戏和学校文件装进五个垃圾袋，扔到了街上。她感到愧疚，因为当初是她把米格尔带到了布伦特伍德，因为她告诉他在学校不要理会那些骚扰他的孩子。当他失踪时，米格尔的东西感觉像是与活着的人的重要联系，但现在它们看起来像是一种谴责。
The coroner listed the cause of death as a blow to the head. Within weeks of discovering Oscar and Miguel's bodies, police also found the body of Jose Pena, the third missing boy from Brentwood High School. He'd been buried in the same woods.
验尸官将死因列为头部重击。在发现奥斯卡和米格尔尸体后的几周内，警方还发现了何塞·佩纳的尸体，第三名来自布伦特伍德高中的失踪男孩。他被埋在同一片树林里。
The double murder of Kayla Cuevas and Nisa Mickens and the police department's race to catch the killers got so much attention, it reached all the way to President Trump, who invited the girls' parents to his first State of the Union address.
凯拉·奎瓦斯和妮莎·米肯斯的双重谋杀案以及警察局抓捕凶手的行动受到了极大的关注，甚至传到了特朗普总统那里，他邀请女孩的父母参加他的首次国情咨文演讲。
Their two teenaged daughters, Kayla Cuevas and Nisa Mickens, were close friends on Long Island. But in September 2016, on the eve of Nisa's 16th birthday-- such a happy time it should have been-- neither of them came home.
她们两个十几岁的女儿，凯拉·奎瓦斯和妮莎·米肯斯，是长岛的好朋友。但在2016年9月，妮莎16岁生日的前夕——那本该是多么快乐的时光——两人都没能回家。
Trump drew a straight line from the girl's murders to the need for stronger immigration laws.
特朗普直接将女孩们的谋杀案与加强移民法的必要性联系了起来。
Many of these gang members took advantage of glaring loopholes in our laws to enter the country as illegal, unaccompanied, alien minors, and wound up in Kayla and Nisa's high school.
这些帮派成员中的许多人利用我们法律中的明显漏洞作为非法、无人陪伴的未成年外籍人士进入该国，并最终进了凯拉和妮莎的高中。
Of course, Miguel and Oscar and Jose were also in that high school. And their disappearances got so much less attention, not just by the president, but by the police. I asked former Commissioner Sini why the police seemed to do so little until the two girls died, especially if they thought the missing boys were homicides.
当然，米格尔、奥斯卡和何塞也都在那所高中。但他们的失踪受到的关注少得多，不仅是总统，还有警方。我问前局长西尼为什么在两名女孩死亡之前，警方似乎做得那么少，特别是如果他们认为失踪的男孩是凶杀受害者。
You know, when you have the double homicide of two high school girls in Brentwood, that's going to provide a catalyst to increase more resources in eradicating MS-13. And that's exactly what we did. If you want to criticize the Suffolk County Police Department for not doing enough against MS-13 prior to September 13, 2016, I suppose you can do that.
你知道，当你在布伦特伍德发生两名女高中生的双重凶杀案时，那将成为增加更多资源铲除MS-13的催化剂。这正是我们所做的。如果你想批评萨福克县警察局在2016年9月13日之前对MS-13做得不够，我想你可以这样做。
Why would you say that?
你为什么那样说？
Well, that's what you're suggesting. So what I'm suggesting to you is that it's clearly a fact that we did increase our efforts against MS-13 on September 13, 2016.
嗯，那是你的暗示。所以我向你暗示的是，这是一个明确的事实，我们在2016年9月13日确实增加了打击MS-13的力度。
It may be true that the police stepped up their efforts after September 13th, but they weren't necessarily effective. The murders continued. In October, a few weeks after the girls were killed, MS-13 killed another 15-year-old immigrant high schooler. When his father reported him missing, police listed him as a runaway. A few days later, a man's body was found in the street.
警察在9月13日之后加强了工作力度可能是事实，但他们不一定有效。谋杀还在继续。10月，在女孩被杀几周后，MS-13又杀死了一名15岁的移民高中生。当他的父亲报失踪时，警方把他列为离家出走。几天后，一个男人的尸体在街上被发现。
After that, it was a suspected rival killed in a deli, then four young men cut up and left together in a gruesome tableau in the woods. All told, the gang killed eight more people by the spring of 2017. By then, MS-13 murders accounted for 40% of homicides in Suffolk County.
在那之后，是另一个在熟食店被杀的敌对帮派成员，然后是四个年轻人被肢解并一起留在了树林里的一幅可怕景象中。总而言之，该帮派在2017年春天之前又杀了八个人。到那时，MS-13谋杀案占了萨福克县凶杀案的40%。
I've spoken with most of the victim's families. All of them are Latino immigrants. And even though their loved ones were killed after September 13th, they all told me they felt ignored and disrespected by the Suffolk County Police.
我和大多数受害者的家人谈过。他们都是拉丁裔移民。尽管他们的亲人是在9月13日之后被杀的，但他们都告诉我他们感到被萨福克县警察忽视和不尊重。
There are lots of ways to frame why the cops treated them like this. The parents say it's because they're immigrants. The DOJ says the department has unlawful bias and discrimination. This one retired Suffolk County detective I talked to had another word for it. His name is Rob Trotta. He's now a county politician. He left the police department a year and a half before Timothy Sini came in.
有很多方法可以解释警察为什么这样对待他们。父母说是因为他们是移民。司法部说该部门存在非法偏见和歧视。我交谈过的一位萨福克县退休侦探对它有另一个定义。他叫罗伯·特罗塔（Rob Trotta），他现在是县政客。他在蒂莫西·西尼上任前一年半离开了警察局。
There is a term among law enforcement. It's called a misdemeanor murder. You know, they're killing each other. I guess it's a bad thing to say they were killing each other, but were killing low income, minority people. Which, you know, is horrible.
执法部门内部有一个术语。叫“轻罪谋杀”。你知道，他们互相残杀。我想说他们互相残杀是一件坏事，但杀的是低收入、少数族裔。这，你知道，是可怕的。
That means like a murder that's not going to get as much attention as the other ones, or you're not going to get as much glory for solving?
这意味着像是不受关注的谋杀，或者你破案不会得到多少荣耀？
No, it's like you know, you're anyone, and there's a murder where someone really got murdered, you're going to put attention to that, because this guy, you know, was-- I don't want to say asking for it. No one should be asking for murder, but clearly he put himself in a position to be killed. Now, that's very different from two girls being murdered, high school girls, by MS-13. That's not misdemeanor murder.
不，就像你知道，你是任何人，有一个人真的被谋杀的案子，你会关注它，因为这家伙，你知道，是——我不想说这是自找的。没人应该自找谋杀，但他显然把自己置于被杀的位置。现在，这与两个女孩被杀，女高中生，被MS-13谋杀是非常不同的。那不是轻罪谋杀。
I asked the Suffolk County Police if their cops use this term. They sent back a statement saying, quote, "Every investigation is rigorously conducted, regardless of victim or circumstances. And department resources are allocated accordingly."
我问萨福克县警方他们的警察是否使用这个术语。他们发回一份声明称，引用：“每一次调查都是严格进行的，无论受害者或情况如何。部门资源也会相应分配。”
But there's another reason why the investigations into the boy's disappearances were so anemic. Several detectives and FBI agents talked to me about it. They said the team who handled cases like this in Suffolk County used to be excellent. This was over a decade ago, starting back in 2003, when the FBI first created a joint gang task force on Long Island.
但调查男孩失踪案之所以如此无力，还有另一个原因。几位侦探和FBI特工和我谈过。他们说萨福克县处理这类案件的团队过去是非常优秀的。那是在十多年前，从2003年开始，当FBI首次在长岛建立联合帮派特别工作组时。
It's basically like a team made up of FBI agents and local detectives. They share intel, fight crime together. Suffolk County Police sent three of its detectives to join them. Rob Trotta was one of those detectives. And for nearly a decade, they had MS-13 on the run.
它基本上是由FBI特工和当地侦探组成的团队。他们共享情报，共同打击犯罪。萨福克县警方派了三名侦探加入他们。罗伯·特罗塔就是其中一名侦探。近十年来，他们让MS-13处处受阻。
I call it the 1978 Yankees, when everything just clicks and you know, we had informants everywhere. They really had a pulse for what was going on. We would cover gang and clique meetings, where we had two people wired up, just so we could see what was going on. If they broke off, we would have conversations and everything.
我称它为1978年的洋基队，当时一切都配合默契，你知道，我们到处都有线人。他们真正掌握了正在发生的事情的脉搏。我们覆盖帮派会议，我们在那两个人身上安装窃听器，只是为了看看正在发生什么。如果他们分开了，我们会进行对话等等。
They shared resources with the feds, who had way more money and training. They solved murders, and even got wind of planned murders before they happened and stopped them. It was going great, until, in 2012, the Suffolk County Police Chief at the time, a guy named James Burke, got into a squabble with the FBI and pulled his detectives from the task force.
他们与联邦调查局共享资源，后者有更多的资金和培训。他们解决了谋杀案，甚至在谋杀发生前就得到了计划的消息并阻止了它们。一切都很顺利，直到2012年，当时的萨福克县警察局长，一个叫詹姆斯·伯克（James Burke）的人，与FBI发生了争执，把他的侦探从特遣部队撤了出来。
Then a few months later, Burke got into big trouble himself for beating up a guy who had been arrested for theft. The thief had stolen a duffel bag from Burke's car, which was weirdly filled with dildos and porn. The FBI started investigating him as a result. Burke was eventually put in prison for violating civil rights and obstructing justice.
几个月后，伯克因为殴打一名因盗窃被捕的人自己惹上了大麻烦。小偷从伯克的车里偷了一个行李袋，里面奇怪地装满了假阳具和色情刊物。FBI因此开始调查他。伯克最终因侵犯民权和妨碍司法公正而入狱。
But one major casualty of the whole fiasco was the department's anti-gang capabilities. They were decimated. When Timothy Sini took over the police department in early 2016, he restored the partnership with the FBI. But by then, Suffolk County had lost out more than three years of MS-13 intel. And it was really hard to catch up.
但整个闹剧的一个主要受害者是该部门的反帮派能力。它们被摧毁了。当蒂莫西·西尼在2016年初接管警察局时，他恢复了与FBI的合作关系。但到那时，萨福克县已经失去了超过三年的MS-13情报。而且真的很难赶上。
Finally, in March of 2017, a year after Miguel first went missing, the FBI gang task force, which now had Suffolk County cops back on it, made a big arrest. They charged two guys, 19-year-old Jairo Saenz and his 22-year-old brother Alexi, with organizing the murders of Kayla and Nisa six months before.
终于，在2017年3月，米格尔失踪一年后，FBI帮派特别工作组，现在又有了萨福克县警察加入，进行了一次大逮捕。他们指控19岁的杰罗·萨恩斯和22岁的兄弟亚历克西在六个月前策划了凯拉和妮莎的谋杀。
The brothers were the leaders of the main MS-13 clique at Brentwood High School, the Sailors. They've pled not guilty. Federal prosecutors have now charged at least 28 people with participating in the MS-13 mayhem on Long Island. It's a massive, ongoing case that includes at least 15 murders, eight attempted murders, arsons, assault, racketeering, and conspiracies to sell marijuana and cocaine.
两兄弟是布伦特伍德高中主要MS-13分支“水手（Sailors）”的头目。他们拒不认罪。联邦检察官现在指控至少28人参与了长岛的MS-13暴力事件。这是一个巨大的、正在进行的案件，包括至少15起谋杀案、8起谋杀未遂、纵火、殴打、敲诈勒索以及贩卖大麻和可卡因的阴谋。
Many of the accused ringleaders are teenagers. The case is still in progress, with new defendants added every few months. At least 10 people have been indicted for the murders of Oscar Acosta, Jose Pena, and the girls, Kayla Cuevas and Nisa Mickens. One person has already pled guilty to killing Jose Pena. But so far, no one's been charged for Miguel's death.
许多被指控的头目都是青少年。此案仍在进行中，每隔几个月就会增加新的被告。至少有10人因奥斯卡·阿科斯塔、何塞·佩纳以及女孩们凯拉·奎瓦斯和妮莎·米肯斯的谋杀案被起诉。已经有一人承认杀害了何塞·佩纳。但到目前为止，还没有人因米格尔的死被起诉。
Carlota won't give Miguel a proper burial until his killer is brought to justice. So in the meantime, his ashes sit on a night stand.
卡洛塔在凶手被绳之以法之前不会给米格尔进行正式葬礼。所以在此期间，他的骨灰放在床头柜上。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
It's been three years, and the police have never come here to tell me anything. They just gave me back my son in a cardboard box. And that's what makes me mad. There are lots of parents, and we're all suffering. So if they could just have a little bit of wisdom, some feeling, some heart, to help us Latinos. I say Latinos, because if they were Americans-- and I'm sorry to say this, but if they were Americans, they would have found someone quickly. But because we're Latinos, we're always left behind.
已经三年了，警察从未到这里来告诉过我任何事。他们只是把我的儿子还给了我，在一个纸盒子里。而那正是让我愤怒的原因。有很多父母，我们都在受苦。所以如果他们能有一点智慧，一点情感，一点心，来帮助我们拉丁裔。我说拉丁裔，因为如果是美国人——我很抱歉这么说，但如果是美国人，他们会很快找到人的。但因为我们是拉丁裔，我们总是被抛在后面。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
I think I know what happened to Miguel. In those Facebook messages from the day he went missing, he and Alexander Lokote talk about meeting up with a guy named Jairo. Alexander wants to meet Miguel at Jairo's house. Jairo says don't bring a friend. Jairo is going to supply the weed. I'm waiting for you at the school with Jairo.
我想我知道米格尔发生了什么。在失踪那天他发的那些Facebook信息中，他和亚历山大·洛科特谈到要和杰罗见面。亚历山大想在杰罗家见米格尔。杰罗说别带朋友。杰罗要提供大麻。我在学校和杰罗等你。
One of the leaders of the MS-13 clique, the Sailors, the guy who's been charged with six murders now, including Oscar's and Kayla's and Nisa's murders, is Jairo Saenz. This summer, I talked to a former member of Jairo's clique, a guy named Henry, who's in immigration detention right now.
MS-13分支“水手”的头目之一，现在被指控六起谋杀案，包括奥斯卡和凯拉、妮莎谋杀案的家伙，是杰罗·萨恩斯。今年夏天，我谈到了杰罗帮派的一名前成员，一个叫亨利的家伙，他现在被关在移民拘留所。
Henry told me, after he joined the Sailors, the first person the clique killed was a chubby Ecuadorean kid. I showed him a picture of Miguel, and he said, yeah, that was him. Henry says Miguel confused the Sailors, because he wore a clashing mix of gang gear. Sometimes, he'd come to school wearing the plastic rosary of MS-13. Other times, he'd be in the head-to-toe black of the 18th Street Gang, or sporting a red bandanna, a sign of the bloods.
亨利告诉我，在他加入“水手”后，帮派杀害的第一个人是一个胖乎乎的厄瓜多尔孩子。我给他看了米格尔的照片，他说，是的，那就是他。亨利说米格尔让“水手”很困惑，因为他穿的帮派装备乱七八糟。有时他戴着MS-13的塑料念珠去学校。有时他会全身穿黑色的“18街”帮派服装，或者是系着红头巾，那是“血帮”的标志。
Henry knew Miguel at school. Sometimes, they'd smoke weed together in the woods. And so one time, Henry says Jairo made him grill Miguel about why he was wearing clothes from these gangs, if he wasn't in a gang. Miguel said he didn't have to explain how he dressed to anyone. Henry thought Miguel was probably trying out gang clothes in an attempt to look cool. But the clique felt disrespected, and that's all it took to get Miguel killed-- a red bandanna.
亨利在学校认识米格尔。有时他们会在树林里一起抽大麻。所以有一次，亨利说杰罗让他盘问米格尔为什么如果不是帮派成员却穿这些帮派的衣服。米格尔说他没义务向任何人解释自己的穿衣方式。亨利认为米格尔可能是在为了显得酷而尝试帮派服装。但帮派成员感到被不尊重了，而这就是导致米格尔被杀的全部原因——一条红头巾。
Hannah Dreier. She's a reporter for ProPublica. This story was a collaboration with them. There's a print version on their web site. ProPublica.org.
汉娜·德雷尔。她是ProPublica的记者。这个故事是与他们合作的。他们的网站上有印刷版本。ProPublica.org。
Something upsetting recently happened on Long Island, that we thought we should point out before we leave this subject. One of the parents who we mentioned in this story, Evelyn Rodriguez, the mother of one of the girls who was killed, was also killed. Not by MS-13. It happened during an argument over the location of a memorial for her daughter. She was one of the parents who Donald Trump invited to the State of the Union address.
最近长岛发生了一件令人不安的事，我们觉得在离开这个话题前应该指出来。我们在故事中提到的一位父母，伊芙琳·罗德里格斯（Evelyn Rodriguez），她是其中一名被杀女孩的母亲，也被杀了。不是被MS-13杀的。这发生在她女儿纪念碑位置的争执中。她是唐纳德·特朗普邀请参加国情咨文演讲的父母之一。
Our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis and Sean Cole. The people who put our show together today includes Elna Baker, Zoe Chace, Whitney Dangerfield, Damian Graef, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Lawrence Lowe, Anna Martin, Nadia Reiman, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Dianne Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们的节目今天由达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）和肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）制作。今天整理我们节目的人包括埃尔纳·贝克（Elna Baker）、佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德（Whitney Dangerfield）、达米安·格拉夫（Damian Graef）、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、劳伦斯·洛（Lawrence Lowe）、安娜·马丁（Anna Martin）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和黛安·吴（Dianne Wu）。我们的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。我们的总编辑是苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）。
Special thanks today to Peter Brill, Rob Bub, David Klinger, Vernon Geberth, Natalie Keyssar, Alexandra Zayas, Dan Golden, and our colleagues at ProPublica.
今天特别感谢彼得·布里尔（Peter Brill）、罗伯·巴布（Rob Bub）、大卫·克林格（David Klinger）、弗农·格伯斯（Vernon Geberth）、娜塔莉·凯萨尔（Natalie Keyssar）、亚历山德拉·扎亚斯（Alexandra Zayas）、丹·戈尔登（Dan Golden）以及我们在ProPublica的同事。
Quick program note. Our program Serial just launched its third season. Sarah Koenig and Emmanuel Dzotsi host. I've been hearing drafts of this for months. I cannot recommend this highly enough. It's about the court system. It gives this very vivid picture of ordinary cases that turn out to be all kinds of incredible in all kinds of ways. You can hear it at serialpodcast.org, or wherever you get your podcasts.
节目通知。我们的节目《Serial》刚刚推出了第三季。莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和伊曼纽尔·佐齐（Emmanuel Dzotsi）主持。我已经听了好几个月的草稿了。我怎么推荐都不为过。它是关于法院系统的。它展示了普通案件非常生动、在各方面都令人难以置信的景象。你可以在serialpodcast.org上收听，或者在任何你获取播客的地方。
This American Life is delivered in to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always our program's co-founder, Tory Malatia. He is still using Yahoo. He says to me all the time, when I try to look up something online--
《美国生活》由公共广播交流平台PRX传送到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Tory Malatia）。他还在用雅虎。当我试图在线查东西时，他总是对我说——
Well, don't Google it.
好吧，别谷歌。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。